well this is this is pretty good news I
think I don't know if you guys heard
heard about this but actually violence
is ended I'm not sure if you heard about
that but we ended violence there is no
more violence violence is done so that's
it
the the hashtag hashtag end violence
trended on Twitter last night
people were is a you know it's a whole
hashtag a bunch of people were tweeting
and violence and I think that the point
these people were making is essentially
what they're saying is look let's just
let's just end violence you know people
were basically arguing that to sum up
their position maybe we could just not
have violence you know maybe maybe we
could explore alternatives to violence
and and that did it I mean all the
violent people in the world
everyone who was engaging in violence or
planning to engage in violence they all
stopped they saw this hashtag and they
stopped and they said oh wait a second
you're saying I should not be violent
and then they slapped their heads or
they kind of laughed they said wow duh
and and and they threw down their guns
and they took off their suicide vests
and they went home to play Parcheesi and
that was that was really the end of it
it was as simple as that
I myself had always been on really if I
it's a to be honest I was more on the
keep violence end of the debate until
this hashtag and I read some of the
tweets and and I thought wow these
people really make an interesting point
and so even I changed my own position my
only thing is if only someone had
thought of this sooner if only someone
had thought to end violence sooner I
think we could have avoided honestly a
lot of heartache in our society but
anyway at least we finally after all
these years you know we finally have
have made the change so I think that's a
really wonderful thing ok speaking of
violence al Sharpton
well he doesn't seem to be much of an
end violence kind of guy
he has throughout his illustrious is
that the word for it I'm not sure maybe
I'll check my thesaurus some kind of
career he has stoked tension and and
violence and riots he's promoted false
rape claims he's engaged in vicious
anti-semitism
he has been generally a grifter and a
hack who does nothing but exploit and
lie and pander in the basest ways
Sharpton is kind of a fascinating
character in a way because he's so
straightforwardly
vile and evil it's just he's there's
there appear to be very few layers to
this guy this is just this is just what
he is to his core and most people know
it that's he's kind of known for that
like I'm not sure if you could find
anyone of any race or ideological
persuasion who would say something
positive about him you know this isn't
just a typical partisan thing where
people on one side say he's awful and
then people on the other side like him
I've never heard anyone any person who
isn't on TV I'm just I've never heard an
average person in a discussion sing his
praises I've never heard that you're
around any group of people and if for
some reason al-shara Tain's name comes
up every doesn't matter what the but the
what the racial or ideological makeup of
the crowd is everyone is there's kind of
that groan and that the rolling of the
eyes and that makes sense because he's
he's transparently fraudulent and that's
why everyone tests him until this week
that is and there's been a sudden shift
on Sharpton this week yeah we'll talk
about that in just a second but before
we do you know today's podcast is
brought to you by even Cheryl watches no
matter what you consider your style to
be no matter what your personal style is
me I don't really have a style I just my
style is I just put on clothing that's
my whole that's my basically my thing
but even for someone like me a quality
classic wristwatch is something that
every guy needs because there's always
going to be an occasion where you need
to dress things up a little bit you need
to look classier and that's where a
classic watch like this one is going to
come into
we're partnering with VIN Cheryl so you
can get a truly stunning watch at an
even more impressive price exclusive for
our listeners when Cheryl is offering a
extra 15% off their exceptionally
crafted watches we have to do is go to
VIN chair o watches comm forward-slash
Walsh and use code Walsh to save an
extra 15% that's VI n CER o watches
dot-com forward slash Walsh and code
walls 50% off ever since we started
working with the guise of a chair oh
they they were nice enough to send me
one of their watches and I'm blown away
with it I've I've been wearing the
chrono s Matt gray non-stop that's
that's this one and every time I wear it
I get complimented on it people pointed
out and as I said for me that's unusual
that someone that I get complimented on
something that I'm wearing so it's it's
sort of a whole new world for me it's
just these are great watches eye
catching good looking bench arrows
strives to be the best value in their
industry and and I think they really are
and you're not gonna find a better maid
watch for this good of a price anywhere
else when it comes to pound to pound
pound for pound for the price you're not
going to do better and I'm not alone in
that opinion if you go to vanaras
website you can read one of the over
15,000 five-star reviews they've gotten
as I said I'm wearing the chrono s Matt
gray but then cher has dozens of watches
and choose from I I've picked my top
five you can go to the website and see
my top five go to have inch arrow
watches comm forward slash Walsh and
don't forget to use code Walsh again for
15% off that's even chera watches VI
ncer o watches comm forward slash Walsh
alright so one day we had left this
pretending to love the city of Baltimore
because Trump criticized it and next we
have Democrats rushing to the defense of
al Sharpton because Trump criticized al
Sharpton you know Trump sent out a bunch
of tweets about Sharpton well you know
that part of the story I don't need to
read the tweets I'm sure you've heard
about that and ever since then over the
past day or so Democrat candidates like
Camille Harris and Joe Biden and others
have come out to say what a wonderful
guy al Sharpton is
and they know better of course and they
would never be so public and explicit in
endorsing Al Sharpton who has more
baggage than you know one of those
luggage carousels at the airport except
that Trump came out against them that's
why that's why they're doing this and
here's here's the amazing thing as many
people have observed the job of for
Democrats in 2020 their path to victory
is really objectively easy extremely
easy and straightforward as in they
could do nothing they could say nothing
they can hold no campaign events even
and just sit there and probably the
Democrat candidate would cruise to
victory fairly easily because that's
just how unpopular and divisive of a
character Trump is like it or not I mean
it's just the he just is really are the
poll numbers and it's pretty clear if
they're gonna say anything if they're
gonna say stuff and they're gonna do
stuff all they really have to do is
limit the stuff they say in the stuff
they do to anything in the not crazy
column that's really pretty much
anything as long as it's not totally
crazy and saying they would be fine but
they can't manage to do even that this
this the bar they have to get over is so
low they can't even get over it they
can't even exercise that minimal
self-control because Trump has this sort
of reverse magnetism that causes them to
whatever he says his ideological
opponents will immediately rush to the
exact opposite position from whatever he
said doesn't matter what he says they're
gonna take the opposite position so
Democrats where comes the Trump are
incapable of taking a moderated stance
on anything they can't counter or they
won't counter Trump's shout
say eccentricities with something
measured and calm and reasonable they
can't do that instead they go to the
other extreme end so to the point where
I think I'd be interesting to see Trump
come out against let's say eating
garbage out of a out of a dumpster he
should send some tweets saying you know
what folks we shouldn't eat garbage out
of dumps you're a loser if you eat
garbage out of dumpster
it's a stupidest thing in the world T
garbage he should just say that because
then you're gonna have Kamil Harris and
and Elizabeth Warren and Joe Biden all
coming out and saying eating garbage out
of the dumpsters the most American thing
it's wonderful it's healthy it's tasty
it's it's it's this this is what true
Americans do any position he takes
they're gonna take the opposite so these
past few days have been the perfect
example perfect illustration of the the
problem for Democrats Trump lashes out
about Baltimore saying that no human
would want to live there and drat infest
it and so on and they could have
responded by saying something like look
he's basically right about Baltimore
Baltimore's got got serious problems
it's a city with tough challenges but
Trump doesn't really care about this
he's just using the issue to divide us
and to cause you know to turn us against
each other etc and so forth yada-yada I
mean they could have gone that route
where it's it's not like they are
explicitly denying the problems in this
city that we all know is a hellhole but
at the same time they're not going to
they're not going to come to Trump's
defense of course I mean I'm not
expecting that they're they're Democrats
they are his ideological enemies after
all but they could have taken that route
but instead they didn't do that instead
they take the diametric extreme opposite
position and say no in fact Baltimore's
great there's nothing wrong with it and
and then they lose they lose that new
cycle they lose that battle and then the
Sharpton thing well Trump comes out and
you know insults al Sharpton fine
and says things about al sharpton that
probably easily 95% of all the people in
the country agree with when it comes to
Al Sharpton so how do the Democrats win
that well they could win it just by
saying nothing
let Sharpton and Trump go back and forth
let them argue and that's that ends up
being a win for Democrats I think or at
least it's a not loss it's not a loss
for them in that case or even better yet
they could come out and say hey I don't
like Trump for XYZ reason but Sharpton
is is a con man too and so I I have no
dog in this fight I'm not getting
involved now that might might be more
difficult for a white a white democrat
to say that but someone like Kamala
Harris if if she were to come out with
with something like that come out
against Al Sharpton I think that would
be an absolute winner for her but
instead no they come out and they
heartily endorse the anti-semite bigoted
fraud and they lose now of course
there's an element of this on the right
- and I don't mean to deny that this is
something this is not just something
that Democrats do this is how our
debates if you want to call them that
work in this country these days where
there's this tendency to define yourself
based on taking the complete opposite
position from your opponent whatever
that happens to be so an example of this
on the right would be something like I
run into this sometimes for instance
with right-wingers who respond to guys
like Kaepernick you ready and and those
who talked about police brutality hey
everyone its Andrew clay by insisting
essentially that it isn't a problem at
all corrupt
it's like corrupt and hey if you don't
want to get beat by the cops Ruth then
you just taking this absolutely book
boot licking anti-american legitimately
all right use that identity Pawar ups
absolute Trump I'm very hesitant and
using that words because it hasn't
like I admit of course it's a few
forward but when you when you say look
if you want to get beat just die just do
what you're told
well the radish that really is basically
a fascist lying and so and their
assumption right when you talk to them
and that's what they'll say you know hey
you don't want to beat do what you're
told because they're taking their
they're taking the they're countering
the excesses of the left when it comes
to the police brutality issue excesses
which are considerable where you've got
leftist running around saying that all
the cops are racist and they're on a
mission to murder black people and that
kind of thing
rather than come out with a nuanced and
measured opposition you see the the
opposite extreme so it happens on both
sides but I think it's it's worse on the
left because of the effect that Trump
has on them where they can't they just
it's as I said it's like it's it's it's
a reverse magnetism thing there's it's
something where they can ditz like they
can't physically help themselves
whatever he says they're on the opposite
and so these are two very winnable new
cycles for the Democrats that they lost
and so they could very easily lose the
election if they continue down this
there's there's no there's no sign of
them changing or or figuring out how to
respond to Trump in a more measured way
there's no sign of that happening so
amazingly they're on the way to losing
well we got more to talk about before we
do these days you know a lot of
workplaces offer some pretty nice perks
snack station fifteen flavors of soda
water even insurance but while it's nice
to have a handful of trail mix and some
water that tastes you know faintly of
lime or lemon you know the which I
actually actually really I'm a fan of
that kind of that's that's the most
millennial thing about me actually is
that I really I enjoy that the
carbonated fancy water I am I admit I'm
a fan of it but that's not enough to
subsist on even if your work
offers that and neither is your
workplace life insurance that's where
policy genius comes in policy genius is
the easiest way to shop for life
insurance online in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the right amount of coverage at the best
possible price the policy genius team
can look at your workplace life
insurance policy and help you decide
what else you might need
and what you don't need importantly
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance whatever
you're looking for for so remember
workplace life insurance policies are
like workplace snacks better than
nothing
but not quite right head to policy
genius.com today and find out how to
supplement your workplace life insurance
and better protect your family policy
genius again it's like a buffet made of
life insurance and what could be more
delicious than that all right before we
before we move to the next topic
there's there's a trend online I you
know you see a lot of these kinds of
videos but I have to play this one for
you I just don't need to set it up any
more than that watch this
[Music]
stubborn Nancy get up the way all you
haters roll and it's gonna get ya okay
that all right I'm just going to move on
this was so here was an interesting
little thing a news report out of
Phoenix Arizona was went viral yesterday
it was a story about a speaking of
policing actually it's a story about a
positive ticketing campaign by cops in
in Arizona Tempe Arizona the plan well
the original story from the local media
or at least the original impression that
was given was that the cops in Tempe
Arizona would be pulling over good
driver
drivers pulling over people who are
obeying traffic laws because they're
obeying traffic laws in order to give
them coupons for a free Slurpee from the
local gas station to reward them for
their good driving well not just a
Slurpee in fairness it could have been
it was it would be a coupon for any
drink you want really any drink you want
at the gas let you get a Diet Coke
amount do so but that's the idea they
pull you over at least that was the the
impression people had based on the story
they'd pull you over and give you a
coupon to reward you for for obeying the
speed limit this idea was met with
backlash I think understandably and a
few hours later the police department
clarified saying no we're not gonna
we're not gonna pull you over okay but
if we happen to see you walking by or
something we might try to engage you in
the conversation and then give you the
coupon as a reward now I'm not sure that
I believe this clarification if the
whole idea is to reward good drivers how
could you do that
unless you see them driving first it
just doesn't make any sense if the idea
is to reward good drivers it would seem
like you'd have to pull them over
because that's the only way that you
would what are cops gonna do walk up to
you and say hey are you a good driver
well I guess I am here's a coupon that
there that seems rather ridiculous
well anyway the now they're not gonna
pull people over it seems likely to me
that maybe that was the original plan
and then they changed it when they got
such a with the backlash from the
feedback was so terrible I don't know
and there is precedent for cops pulling
people up people over to Pat them on the
head for being good little boys and
girls you may remember this from a few
years ago okay so there they were
pulling people over to give out ice
cream in Arizona they claimed they were
never intended to do anything like that
which okay fine but it raises it raises
a question about this whole idea of cops
going around handing out little prizes
and commendations for people who are
following the law and I've heard of
other things like this another in other
places I don't know if doesn't always
involve pulling people over but the
whole the whole concept I'm not a big
fan of as far as pulling people over to
give them a coupon or an ice-cream that
is clearly a terrible idea on a number
of levels levels you are you're
interrupting the flow of traffic you're
pulling somebody off the road when they
could be in a hurry I mean you don't
know what they could be late for work
could be late for an appointment
important appointment you don't know
what's going on with them yet you're
doing that and you're causing a lot of
stress as well you're making people
think that they're in trouble it's very
it's very stressful thing when you see
those sirens go off and so you're doing
all of that just so you can give them a
little prize worth a dollar 25
that's it's not what police are supposed
to be doing and it's not fair to
citizens who are forced to take part in
the stunt because the moment you see the
sirens go off behind you you are
essentially being detained at least
temporarily I mean for all intents and
purposes you're being detained because
you you have to pull over you don't have
a choice and you have to comply with
whatever they're saying so to use that
power and authority for something like
this is obviously an abuse to detain
people even for five minutes so that you
can play a little prank or give out
coupons or do a little you know
publicity stunt a little PR thing is
completely wrong not to mention what if
what if the cop comes up with the coupon
or the ice cream or whatever and and
they smell weed in the car or they see
contraband of some kind what do they do
because they pulled you over under false
pretenses they they they they pulled you
over for with no suspicion no reasonable
suspicion of illegal activity and let's
say they they come up with the ice cream
or the coupon and then they see illegal
activity going on can they even make an
arrest in a situation like that I'm not
sure but it opens up a whole can of
legal worms here that just renders the
whole thing completely absurd and not
worth it at all
but really the main thing is this if I'm
obeying the law leave me alone just
leave me alone let me be that's the best
reward for me I think for most people
let me go about my day that's all if I'm
obeying the law my reward is that I
don't have to deal with cops to be
detained you know I I don't have to do
any of that I don't have to have that
stress I could just I can I have my
freedom and my Liberty I can go about my
day and I have my time to myself and
that's what I want that's the best
reward so let me have that which is why
even the idea of giving out coupons to
people on foot you know I don't like
that idea there I'm not into that for
the same reason
that I don't need they just let me be
please
now if the point here is to improve the
relationship between cops and the
citizens then I think that's a worthy
goal it's a nice idea I mean it's it's
like if it's the thought that counts and
in fact a lot more than the thought
counts but if that's all that counted
then it would be fine because it's a
nice thought but let me suggest a better
method you don't need a promotional
stunt you don't need ice cream
you don't need coupons I think instead
what you could do is simply train police
officers to be generally friendly to the
community to law-abiding members of the
community especially friendly and
helpful in general they don't need to
give out free stuff but just be friendly
and welcoming to people and and
approachable
and and you could train them even when
they're pulling someone over for a minor
traffic violation and they're given the
person to take it you could train them
to not be jerks about it train them to
treat their fellow citizens as fellow
citizens not serfs not subjects and a
lot of cops already do this the majority
of cops already do this so they don't
you don't need to train them that's what
they already do and that's great and
those are police officers who are very
much helping with the relationship
between the community and law
enforcement and to give those cops
coupons to give out or something is it's
not just demeaning and patronizing for
the citizens it is for them too I feel
bad for the cops of the situation
because I'm sure they don't have a
choice they have to do it I would
certainly hate it if I was a police
officer and you were wasting my time
with stuff like this and I have to do it
I don't have a choice
so I feel bad for them as well my point
is simply that all the coupons in the
world aren't gonna compensate for cops
who struggle in this area of simply
being nice and friendly you know to the
community especially to law abiding as
members of the community any police
officer who struggles in that area it's
it's you're not going to compensate for
that with
coupons and if they don't struggle in
that area then the coupons are
unnecessary it's an it's an added thing
that just makes it weird and awkward and
there's no reason for it so that's what
I would say and you know the last thing
too is I don't I don't like I think like
most people these days I don't I'm not a
fan of participation trophies the idea
that anyone should be given any kind of
prize at all simply for obeying the law
I don't like that because obeying the
law is our right it's our civic duty
it's it's like it's a it's a bare
minimum it's just it's what we're
supposed to do that's why if you don't
obey the law you get in trouble you get
fine or you go to jail
because it's expected that you could at
least do this as a citizen so we talked
about the responsibilities of police
officers well the responsibility for us
is you know obeying a law is bare
minimum stuff so to give us essentially
a civic participation trophy it saying
congrats for not breaking the law no we
don't we don't not only are you wasting
our time but it's also we don't deserve
that even something like a coupon we
don't deserve that simply for breaking
for obeying the law it's so the whole
idea is is awful
let's see there was one other story in
The Daily wire about well maybe we'll
say the
for tomorrow I'll read a little bit from
this story in the daily wire a report
few days ago that went viral for for
good reason
reading a bit from the report it says
John Doe as he is referred to in court
documents review by Daily wire was
accused of sexually assaulting a student
referred to as Jane row at the end of
January 2018 and this is at Pennsylvania
State University the two had met the
previous spring since they are both
parts of the part of the Schreyer Honors
College of January 26 2018 the two met
up again in a computer lab and started
talking they then started flirting and
Jane put her number in the John's phone
according to the lawsuit and texted
herself I love you from John's phone as
a means of giving herself John's number
and they continued to flirt and we're
walking through how their relationship
progressed because it's important for
the for what happened next so okay so
it's a flirtatious relationship
eventually they end up in they end up in
Jane's room which she invited John to
her room and they engage in sexual
activity the lawsuit claims that Jane
Lane later it was a totally consensual
act the lawsuit claims that Jane later
changed her account of the sexual
encounter to claim that John physically
forced her into sex and that she tried
to get away from him which according to
the lawsuit was was was not the case at
all but here's the okay here's so this
so far it's it's a story that
unfortunately we've heard many times of
according to according to the lawsuit
anyway you know you have a consensual
encounter that after the fact turns
non-consensual because the woman changed
her mind and decided she regretted it
and so on which of course you you never
hear the reverse of that I mean this
what some people may think there have
been occasions in the history of mankind
even in recent American history there
probably a cave there probably
frequently occasions where there's a
sexual encounter between a guy and a
girl and the guy later regrets it and
wishes he hadn't done that but you never
hear about the guy coming back and
saying yeah you know what actually I I
wasn't into that I was raped you you
never hit and if a guy did do that I
think he'd probably be laughed out of
the room nobody would take him seriously
so this is something that only women are
able to do it's a kind of female
privilege well the hearings panel chair
told okay they said that the panel felt
this is the panel that was you know
looking into these allegations at the
school they felt that the respondents
continual flattery constitutes cajoling
which they gave several examples they
gave several examples of what they felt
the guy was consoling cajoling the the
girl into sex by flattering her and some
of the examples they gave these are all
just constitute text messages that he
sent flirty sort of text messages so
when they say cajoling it's not like he
was trying to blackmail her or
intimidate her and Emma says but no he
was just he called her beautiful stuff
like that complimented her normal things
that guys say the girls especially if
they're in a relationship of some kind
with them and so the school decided that
the flattery is a controlling into
sexual intercourse and therefore it's a
form of sexual assault that's all
according to the lawsuit I mean this is
you want to talk about the slippery
slope this is this is where we are now
and it yet again underscores how
dangerous it is and I
maybe this is the takeaway for people
that are in if you're in college if
you're a guy or or a woman either way to
engage and you know the hook-up culture
and everything it's it's a it's a
dangerous game to play dangerous on a
number of levels I mean aside from the
diseases and everything that are
possible there's also this element of it
now
now just completely insane all right
we'll go to emails Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
this is from Dave says hey Matt I've
been navigating my own beliefs on the
death penalty as a Catholic Francis
recently scrubbed a bunch of latitude
and personal interpretation from the
Catechism I naturally resonate with the
thoughts you presented in a recent
podcast I'd love to hear your thoughts
on squaring Catholic faith and this
belief as most of the Catholic talkers
are militantly anti-death-penalty yeah
we talked about the death penalty and I
shared that I am I'm in favor of the
death penalty although as I've talked
about over over the course of of the
last couple of years I've kind of
flip-flopped on this issue but I'm now
pretty firmly in favor of it for reasons
that I outlined I'm not going to get
into it again but I have gotten several
emails like this from people saying well
I thought as a Catholic don't you have
to be against the death penalty because
the Pope came out and said that the
death penalty is impermissible or I
forget the phrase he used that I think
that was the exact word something like
impermissible inadmissible maybe in in
typical Pope Francis fashion there was a
little bit of vagueness and ambiguity in
the way that it was phrased but it is
true that they made this change the
Catechism what I'll say though Dave is
that Catholic teaching azzam as you
probably are aware Catholic teaching on
the death penalty has referred for 2000
years the church taught that the death
penalty is at least in principle
acceptable not just acceptable actually
but but
could be the the morally right things it
could be it could be necessary forward
for justice that's what the Catholic
Church taught for 2,000 years
importantly that is also clearly what
Scripture teaches I mean you have God in
his own words in the Old Testament on
numerous occasions commanding the death
penalty not not simply saying oh yeah
you could do that if you want but saying
you must do it for crimes like murder
for instance so that's that's what I
know as a Catholic and I know that the
Pope does not have the authority to on
his own
simply overturn that the Pope can't
overturn what God said he can't and the
Pope also can't get up there and say oh
you know what the church was actually
wrong about this for 2,000 years because
I say so
it's my you know in my opinion they were
wrong so they were the Pope can't do
that so I guess my answer is I'm you
know I'm not in disagreement with the
church I'm not in disagreement with
Scripture I am in disagreement with Pope
Francis himself personally and I'm
perfectly free to disagree with him all
right this is from Taylor says in high
school I came across one of your blogs
and I've been following your work ever
since I admire your intellectual honesty
and wit and you seem like a good person
in general well I don't know about any
of that but thank you Taylor I
especially like the episode of your show
in which she discussed philosophy you
mentioned a few episodes ago that you're
naturally interested in philosophical
questions we have this in common I'm a
graduate student in philosophy now and I
was wondering if you had any favorite
non theological philosophical arguments
it doesn't have to be an explicitly
deductive argument perhaps there's a
thought experiment or analogy you find
particularly interesting if so could you
explain the argument and what you like
about it okay so you're asking for a
favorite philosophical art question or
argument that doesn't explicitly deal
with God or
or anything theological it's an
interesting question of course at the
end of the day everything goes back to
these theological questions as I'm sure
you probably agree so you can't really
separate it completely but in terms of
Thea or of philosophical questions that
aren't explicitly theological well I
would say and this relates to the
philosophical question we were
discussing when I made the comment that
you're referring to about philosophy I
am very interested in the nature of
consciousness and again that has a lot
of theological implications of course
but still it's something that I find
fairly fascinating the nature of the
self of consciousness and so on I think
it's a very interesting field
philosophical field not just
philosophical but as I said also
theological scientific there's a thought
experiment that touches on the nature of
self and consciousness a couple actually
the philosopher Thomas Nagel which you
you probably you're getting a if you're
going to school for philosophy you've
probably heard about this but he wrote a
famous essay called what is it like to
be a bat and it deals with the question
of consciousness and conscious
experiment experience and he asks the
question is there an experience of
badness for lack of a better term do
bats really experienced being bats the
way that you experience being a human do
they think anything at all about
themselves about what they're
experiencing is it like something to be
a bat or to be a squid or to be a sloth
or to be you know a dog or whatever and
I think that's a that is a interesting
question another thought experiment that
I think we've talked about before on
this show it was first proposed by a
philosopher in the in the 80s I think
maybe 70s or 80s and this is the thought
experiment is this imagine we live in a
future where it's possible to transplant
a brain into a new body which probably
eventually
scientists will be able to doctors will
be able to do that they're not close
right now but let's just imagine that
was possible
now suppose because remember it is
possible to live with half a brain so
suppose that your brain is cut in two
and then one half of the brain is
transplanted into one body and the other
half is transplanted into another body
where did you go what happened to you
your brains cut to transplant in
different bodies what happened to you I
think that's an interesting question
which one is you are you both now well
that seems impossible
are you are you neither did you simply
disappear and if so then what who who
replaced you are you one and not the
other and then if that's the case who's
the other guy I mean it's an interesting
question I think of course purely
hypothetical and as just what a thought
experiment is I don't even if they get
to the point where they can transplant
brains and even though we can survive
with half a brain I don't think there
will ever be a situation where they
would actually transplant half a brain
into someone's head but you know this is
from Samuel says hello Matt it listened
to your show fairly regularly and I very
much enjoy it I agree with you for the
most part but there are a few things
that I don't
the reason I'm writing today is to
challenge your idea that as adults we
should not hang on to our childhood
enjoyment story slash movies in
particular as an adult I have grown to
really appreciate a lot of children's
stories and movies much more than I when
I was younger
even CS Lewis said that he enjoyed stor
children's stories more as an adult
thank you for the work you do and I look
forward to getting my point-of-view
roasted on your show but I got a Roy
roast your point of view I think it is
it is possible to appreciate children's
stories as an adult you know I'll read
stories to my kids and I can appreciate
those stories so I'm not saying we don't
appreciate them but I do think that look
the Bible says I became a man and put
away childish things I think to a
certain extent and I'm you know
and people people always counter that I
don't remember the exact quote but the
CS Lewis quote you're referring to
people always counter that scripture
quote with the CS Lewis thing even
though CS Lewis was not he wasn't trying
to disagree with Saint Paul when he says
when he said what you're what you're
referring to so I think that my point is
simply as we grow older our tastes
should mature to some extent so while we
could still appreciate childish things
childlike things we can appreciate them
to some extent you know in a certain way
we appreciate them as adults and I think
we also have mature tastes as well
that's why I was saying the interesting
thing about being a parent is that you
go back and you kind of relive your
childhood in many ways you're
experiencing all the things you
experienced as a child again but now
you're experiencing it as an adult as a
parent from a different perspective I
think the problem is when you have
adults that are clinging on to their
childhood and still experiencing those
childlike things almost like children
themselves not from a new perspective
not you know reliving it as a parent or
something but refusing to leave
childhood to begin with and also I would
say I think there's a difference between
you know when someone like CS Lewis
talks about fairy tales for children we
got to keep in mind see us Lewis I mean
he was writing back in the early to mid
20th century mid 20th century anyway and
still even back then for the most part
you know the fairy tales that did that
he was talking about they're not the
same as the kind of as comic book movies
today I think fairy tales back in those
days
we're often you know often did have very
mature themes and they were for children
but they also they they also had a
certain depth to them I guess is the
point that I think a lot of the stuff
for kids these days that has just has no
depth
and that's one of the reasons why
usually as you grow older and you become
an adult you these days I think at least
for me as I've grown older I I can't
enjoy some of those childlike things the
same way because it's just it has no
depth there's nothing to it and as you
get older you start to see that all
right this is from Paul says have you
seen this video regarding your minimum
wage discussion and then there's a link
to the video and this is a video from
someone named Sam cedar titled is Matt
Walsh the laziest right winger in media
apparently it's a response to my - what
I said about minimum wage the email goes
on although I'm a free-market capitalist
and opposed to minimum wage they do make
an interesting point about when people
provide more work than they're being
paid I certainly understand that it's
very difficult to really measure the
value of someone's work and I think that
we need to be grateful for the
opportunity to work and should always
try to do the best job possible out of
gratitude if nothing else but I'm very
interested to hear your rebuttal to this
video keep up the good work yeah Paul I
hadn't seen this video but I will watch
it it's okay it's 17 minutes long
rebuttal to what I said about I'll watch
it and I'll if if there's anything
interesting there I will provide a
response on the show but thank you for
bringing it to my attention I will leave
it to everybody thanks for watching
Godspeed hey everyone its Andrew Clavin
host of the Andrew Clavin show politics
corrupts but identity politics corrupts
absolutely trump has broken through that
evil racist system not politely I admit
more like The Incredible Hulk walking
through a wall the question is now that
the wall is down will the rest of us
have the courage to run free we'll talk
about it on the Andrew Clavin show I'm
Andrew Clavin